after last year i think we're all ready
for some outdoor fun
here to give us a look at this summer's
hottest toys is lori leahy with ttpm
hi lori first off what does ttpm stand
for
it stands for toys pets and more
so you guys know your stuff then it's
what you're telling me what toys do you
have for us today
yeah so we've got a lot of outdoor toys
from our spring most wanted list we're
going to start with something for the
pool fans
the new swimways spring float line is
a new hypervalve technology so that
means
it's going to be easier and faster to
inflate and that means that you're going
to get in the pool and relax a lot
faster which we think
that teens and adults are really going
to like and that starts at ages 14 and
up
what i love about this is the way you
inflate the thing it's not that
old-school little nozzle you're sticking
your lips on you just blow into this
thing
and it inflates it right yeah and it's
one of those things where you think
how could they have you know
revolutionized inflating and inflatable
but they have it's really cool
it's perfect all right what's the next
toy you have for us all right so
something else for the older teens and
adults is the
nerf rival curve so this is from hasbro
and
it's a blaster uses this little ball
ammo so it's a little bit more
sophisticated than the traditional nerf
darts
and what's cool about this it's called
the curve because you can adjust the
nozzle
and curve and aim left or right it also
has a really cool
curved design which i love and i think
nerf fans are going to love as well
so if you are ages 14 and up this is a
great way to get some active play
outside i see kids in my neighborhood
doing the nerf fights all the time and
this thing's fantastic you shoot that
nerf straight no
whizz around the tree and boom it's your
target it's the coolest thing ever
exactly more strategy more control over
over your firing
yes yes what else do you have for us
okay so this one's more for the little
ones
this is fomo from mga this is just one
of the refill
bottle solutions so it's a much larger
device but it's a foam making machine so
you set it up you turn it on
and it just blows mounds and mountains
of foam so if you're having a birthday
party outside or any sort of outdoor
gathering this summer
kids are going to go crazy for this
they're going to run it in it throw in
it whatever
and parents will love that it's very
easy clean up i used it on my driveway
and grass and just hosted it all down at
the end
very easy and it's a little bit of an
investment of an investment
but these refills you purchase them and
you can use this over and over again so
something that's definitely going to see
you through
the entire summer season we are in las
vegas i think adults can use that at
pool parties as well so what's the last
item you got for us less than 30 seconds
here what's the last one all right so
this is the spider-man bubble slinger
from little kids
you wear it it plays sounds and
character phrases so kids can pretend to
be spider-man while they are blowing
bubbles instead of slinging web
it's a great character role play as well
as outdoor active bubble chasing play
it's perfect with the new spider-man
movie coming out this year thank you so
much lori we appreciate it for more
information visit ttpm.com
las vegas now we'll be right back